you were in a coma for two weeks I can't  remember anything  this is really in my house I'm so sorry  I wasn't here to greet you  I just went to town to get some  groceries thank you the white roses are  my favorite I know ma'am maybe I don't  remember anything and I got into this  terrible car accident or the coastal  road nearby I get the feeling that they  just made it all up  why were you looking at me like that  oh you've been thinking about me in ways  you wouldn't even imagine nobody here I  mean I'm not sure if there were loose  Nations or if they were just memories I  am NOT well sir everything his case  would be fine I just don't want to lose  you  [Music]  but it varies  [Music]  I will be fine for the first time in  ages I feel so alive  well  there's nothing inside of me except this  big dark avoid I think I'm in love with  her you destroyed us  [Applause]  you  you